how soon after a how soon after did you
know I think we have a hit on our hands
or B did you and and B did you ever
think
is your job in Jeopardy do you think
you're gonna get fired oh dude I thought
I was gonna get fired for the first
three to four years of of of you know
doing the show why because they actually
made us so it was actually kind of
something that they did that was
somewhat unfair so a lot of young kids
on the show a lot of party kids a lot of
like you know without you know everyone
was in their like early 20s you know and
they're all just like going out and
getting hammered and you know screwing
around with each other yeah and and and
so the first you know Season you know
was like a lot of people were showing up
to work late a lot of like you know
things of that nature and I wasn't man I
was taking this [__] so seriously I was
literally sitting at home studying my
lines and trying to and working out and
getting in shape for the role and all
that crap but they said from the
beginning you know they brought us all
in and they said just so you guys know
you're all Expendable every one of you
they say every yeah every single one of
you this isn't the this isn't the the
the my character's name was Stefan this
isn't the step often Diaries this isn't
the Elena Diaries this is the you know
this is the Vampire Diaries and any one
of you can go and they they and so I was
we were all petrified
worst thing to do yeah and it really put
this back what they do though yeah it is
they want you not to we don't know if
the show's gonna get picked up yeah well
what do you mean the numbers are
outraged yeah I don't know yeah hey
renegotiations exactly this means I'm a
part of an integral part of so I'll make
some more money well this show is paying
for a lot of our shows that are failing
so what are you talking about right in
the real world you part of a business
and you know you're an integral part
yeah hopefully it doesn't always happen
but yeah that's that's kind of yeah yeah
no I mean it it was a way and I will say
it worked because people started to not
to not show up late Etc but for myself I
was a little bit like man like you know
I I was already taking it very seriously
but in any case so yes I always felt
like I was going to get fired um as far
as the question you know did I know we
had a hit like this was before Twitter
and Instagram and all this crap too you
don't know yeah you know so it's not
like you can like go on and see that
it's a trending you know show or
whatever the hell
um and so I just remember being like I
guess people are watching this I don't
know and you know with the um overnight
ratings and all that like you never know
you hear about the ratings like a few
days later but I remember just this very
distinct
um I was moment I was in uh Atlanta and
the pilot or the season it just started
airing and
um I just remember I was staying at like
the W Hotel for some bizarre reason
and I walked down the lobby and someone
goes oh you're the guy from the vampires
and I just remember being like oh wow no
way you watched the show I was so
excited it was my first time getting
recognized from the show and then I go
to the and I was super happy and I go
down to the valet and the ballet is like
you're the guy from the Barrett and then
I pulled up to some other places because
you're the guy and I went oh [__] like
five people just recognized me like
within the span of like seven minutes
and I thought okay maybe maybe if uh
people are watching this and then after
that that was that was when I knew we
had a hit that's that's amazing you know
my reality was then
was I always felt like the poor me but I
always felt like
um I just wasn't important I wasn't
anybody I wasn't and so when I started
getting recognized that people came up
to me I felt like oh wow
I am somebody right I'm somebody I'm
someone yeah they notice me someone
notices me yeah it was kind of a and you
had such a distinct because you shaved
your head yeah you know you commit it's
not like you put a uh one of those no
thank God by the way I begged for them
and you look great with a shaved head
thank you I I know what I mean so but
thank thank you well because it could
have gone South you could have just
shaved it because everybody had to look
good right right I was always scared I
was gonna get fired I've told this story
before but like I always felt like
you know I have a bump on the back of my
head I'm not as good looking as the
other cast members I'm kind of awkward
I'm like the I don't know I'm not a nap
you were the best thing in the show oh
thank you well thanks for saying that no
I really feel that way but I think a lot
of people felt that way you know it's
funny I I didn't hear that until I think
really the show ended really I mean I
never I heard oh you're great you're
like but I I it was almost like years
after the show it now it starts to
I I hear it more like people at
conventions and people that are but I
didn't hear that you're you're the best
I remember I remember like a very
specific
I I I I I don't remember I look it's
been a while but I just remember like
having that sort of like impression when
I got on the show I was like oh he's
like the the you know with all due
respect to all the other cats I was like
he's like the interesting like I thought
your choices were interesting your style
was interesting things you were doing
were interesting it was like much less
sort of CW right and it was a little
more sort of like
um a different approach which I which I
really respected thank you yeah you know
honestly I think a lot of that has to do
with also the writing you know giving me
things that are interesting right
different scenes with more mature people
right but look at the end of the day yes
9 out of 10 girls favorite characters
that's the one of course cool chick yeah
that's like hey yeah all right
which I love yeah